three
two one zero
from the earliest days of apollo when
nasa landed the first humans on the moon
ibm has had the distinct honor of
playing a key role in nasa's space
exploration efforts fast forward 50
years to today
when the international space station is
helping to lay the groundwork
for living and working in space a
baseline for future nasa missions
traveling at over 17 000 miles per hour
and orbiting the earth every 90 minutes
the iss offers a one-of-a-kind
microgravity environment
where crew members perform research that
cannot be done anywhere else
critical research like dna sequencing on
the iss
provides foundational knowledge that
will be essential as nasa seeks to
venture further into space
than ever before however analyzing this
research
often requires data to be downlinked to
earth and processed by personnel
on the ground a procedure that can take
several weeks and delay results
that's where ibm comes in in partnership
with nasa
iss national lab hpe and red hat
ibm created the edge computing and space
solution
eliminating the need to move massive
libraries of dna sequencing data
by presenting containerized analytical
code locally
right on the iss where the data
originates
this solution has the potential to cut
analysis time by nearly 50 percent
opening the door for many new mission
possibilities
in addition nasa researchers will use
this platform to more rapidly develop
test and push code to the iss in a
fraction of the time
by leveraging red hat code-ready
containers and connecting to ibm cloud
running openshift on the ground
this groundbreaking partnership will not
only expedite nasa's iss
research but will help to lay the
foundation for future exploration
opportunities
on iss and beyond
we can't wait to support what comes next
you